hello and welcome to GS news for March
14th your regular host just couldn't
make it today I'm sorry but if you want
to can hit that subscribe button watch
me embarrass myself on the regular you
might remember a time long ago when the
xbox 360 and ps3 were new consoles when
the switch was just a gleam in
Nintendo's I and GTA 5 was a new game
well GTA online continues to get updates
the latest update called cunning stunts
special vehicle circuit introduces a new
set of races new cars and it's out today
the crazy races involve equipping a
parachute to your car and taking to the
skies zipping through the water on an
amphibious vehicle and strapping a
rocket to your ride and driving through
a psychedelic rainbow road like course
from now through March 22nd all of the
cunning stunts races will pay out double
GTA bucks and RP as for the future
Rockstar tia is that new options are
still coming to creator mode such as sub
props and the ability to craft your own
course for those special vehicles
waiting sucks waiting in line waiting
for the next season of Game of Thrones
to start waiting for me to get to the
point of this story but you don't have
to wait much longer for the next
overwatch hero well Risa has been on PTR
for a while now and she'll be released
officially across all platforms on
Tuesday March 21st overwatch director
Jeff Kaplan described her slightly
longer than usual stay on the testing
server as something that will be for the
better sensor introduction or reese's
weapon damage and ultimate have already
been hit with a few nerves so it'll be
interesting to see how much balancing
she goes through before her final
release if you're one of those gamers
were eagerly awaiting Mass Effect
Andromeda well some gamers are reporting
that they can already start pre-loading
the game but don't worry yourself time
to finish the video you just preloaded
you can't play it sit back down
developer Bioware hasn't made an
official announcement on the pre-loading
but users across Twitter and reddit have
been able to start downloading the game
to their consoles this is also revealed
the initial console file size of 40 2.19
gigabyte song xbox one and 42.9 on ps4
previously announced pc specs
recommended having 55 gigs free but it's
important to keep in mind that the game
is supposed to have a day one patch
available later this week Mass Effect
launches on March 21st but if you're an
EA
subscriber you'll be able to play a few
hours starting on march 16th but if you
want to see the game in action now we
have a single player live stream on the
gamespot channel going up today and a
multiplayer livestream tomorrow and
that's the news for march 14th didn't
get enough mass effect be sure to stay
tuned to our channel where you can watch
45 minutes of the opening game play and
this weekend we're going to have a
feature that dives deep into the origins
of the game and if you got enough of me
don't worry jess is going to be back
next week